LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
HEARING. BEFORE WE GET STARTED
TODAY. I'D LIKE TO MAKE A FEW
REMARKS. I FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT
TO KNOW TO MAKE NOTE OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN OUR STATE AND
COUNTRY AT THIS MOMENT. WE ARE
HERE TO DELIBERATE ON THE BILL
BUT WE ARE ALSO HERE TO
CONTINUE TO RUN OUR GOVERNMENT
FOR THE PEOPLE. IF TWENTY
TWENTY HAS TAUGHT US ANYTHING
SO FAR IT'S OUR THAT OUR WORK
PROVIDING EQUAL PROTECTION
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERY
CALIFORNIA. IS FAR FROM DONE. I
DO NOT CONDONE VIOLENCE.
VIOLENCE AGAINST PERSONS
WALKING. JOGGING FOR DRIVING
THROUGH OUR STREETS NOR
VIOLENCE AGAINST INNOCENT SHOP
OWNER EVEN AS WE PROTEST FOR
RIGHT JUST BECAUSE- OUR WORK
WILL NOT BE DONE UNTIL EVERY
FAMILY EVERY PERSON CAN LIVE
THEIR LIVES AND PURSUE THEIR
DREAMS WITH EQUAL ACCESS. AND
IN SAFETY. I RE COMMIT MYSELF
TO THAT MOST BASIC GOAL TODAY.
AS I HOPE MY COLLEAGUES AND
EVERY RESIDENT OF OUR STATE
WILL. AS WELL. DUE TO THE
CURRENT STAY AT HOME ORDER WE
ARE PARTICIPATING WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING.
WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES
TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM. TODAY IN RECOVERY
ARE IN A ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO.
YOU'RE HAVING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING. IN
THE SPACE WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS A SMALL STAFF AND A
LUMP IN A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAINED SIX FOOT SPACING.
THERE ARE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM TODAY. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IT IS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON THE BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND. AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU HAVE DONE TESTIFYING
BEFORE YOU MAY RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE UP LEAVING
THE CAPITOL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. WE WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE. ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU WERE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLANTED PLAN TO DO SO
WHEN THE AUTHOR BEGINS
PRESENTING HIS BILL. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WE'LL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES COMMUTING
YOUR LIVE STREAM BROADCAST. AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE
ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE.
IF YOU ARE A PRIMARY WITNESS
YOU'LL REMAIN ON A LIFELINE I
WILL NEED TO MUTE YOUR PHONE
UNTIL YOU ARE ASKED TO SPEAK.
IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATED PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL OUR
COMMITTEE OFFICE AT. NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE THREE NINE
FIVE EIGHT. AND MY STAFF WILL
ASSIST YOU. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL O THE WEBSITE ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
AS METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE HAVE A FEW
ADDITIONAL HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS
TO GO OVER BEFORE WE START. WE
HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE AGENDA
TODAY SB SIX TWENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD BRADFORD. WE
ALSO HAVE REPLACEMENT MEMBER
TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE HAS
BEEN ASSIGNED TO REPLACE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROMMEL'S. WE
WILL TAKE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THESE
WITNESSES HAVE THREE. MINUTES
EACH TO PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY
ALL SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAMETHEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY. WE WILL
REFRAIN WE WILL REFRAIN FROM
PERSONAL ATTACKS AGAINST. OR IN
PLUNGING THE MOTIVES OF MEMBERS
STUFF WITNESSES OR ANY OTHER
PARTY TO THIS PROCEEDING WE
WILL FOCUS OUR COMMENTS AND
DISCUSSION ON THE POLICY MERITS
OF THE BILL BEFORE US. I SEE
THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
HERE LACKEY YOUR ACKEY HERE
BLOOM HERE HELLO HERE
BOERNER HORVATH HERE REMEMBER
THAT HERE STONE. THREE OF US
HERE WE HERE ROBERT YEAH ROBERT
REED OF PEER VOEPEL GO WELCOME
HERE. THANK YOU HAVE A- I SEE A
SOMEONE JONES SARS TO PRESENT
THE BILL ON CENTER BRAD BUT HOW
PLEASE PROCEED ASSEMBLY MAY
JONES SAWYER. THANK YOU MADAM.
AND MEMBERS OF LOCAL COMMITTEE.
OF LET ME JUST SAY BEFORE I TO
HOPEFULLY. EVERYBODY'S ABLE TO
ACCESS TO THE HEARING BOB WERE
SOME INTO THAT COULD GET AN
EARLY BECAUSE OF NON ONLY COPE
IT. BUT DID. CIVIL THING
THEY'RE HAPPY WITH INTO CITY IN
OTHER CITIES THE- SO HOPEFULLY
THE- THAT WEREN'T A TO GET A- I
KNOW THERE WERE SOME TECH.
DIFFICULTIES BEING ABLE TO IT.
HOPEFULLY WE- THIS BECAUSE PART
OF THIS. I READ WHY WE HAVE
COMMITTEES HE SAID IT CAN HEAR
EVIDENCE FOR EVERY. AND WE CAN
HEAR FROM EVERYONE CONSERVE.
AND SO I MADE TECH. OUTSIDE
THAT THE THAT WOULD HAVE.
INCIDENTS SO HOLD WE ARE ABLE
TO DO THAT. SB SIX TWO FIVE.
WELL HOW RESOLVE THE KERN GO.
CRISIS AT THE CENTRAL.
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT. THE
BORDER. FOR THE DISK ARE. AS A
RESULT THE I. OF THE DISTRICT
IS IN DISARRAY IN HIS DUTIES
NEGLECTED. SB SIX TWO FIVE
TAKES IMMEDIATE ACTION TO
REMEDY THE SITUATION BY PLACING
THE DISTRICT INTO RECEIVERSHIP.
AT THE WATER REPLENISHMENT
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AT THE SAME TIME THIS BILL WILL
INSTRUCT THE LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSION O LEFT GO
TO ORGANIZE A PUBLIC PROCESS OF
REVIEW. IN ORDER TO RECOMMEND
LONG TERM GOVERNMENT GOVERNANCE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THIS
LEGISLATURE. THIS LEGISLATURE
STEMS. FROM A SIGNIFICANT AND
LONG HISTORY OF THE DISTRICTS
IN ABILITY TO MEET ITS
RESPONSIBILITY. A TWENTY
FIFTEEN STATE AUDIT POINTED OUT
ISSUES A POOR LEADERSHIP DISHES
ARE MAKING AN OVERSIGHT THAT
HAS LED TO VIOLATIONS OF STATE
LAW.A MASSIVE DROP IN BOTH THE
RESERVE FUNDS FROM TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION TO NINE POINT EIGHT
MILLION. AND DISK DECREASE OF
THE DISTRICTS BOND HEARING BOND
RATING. FOLLOWING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE- ATTEMPTS
WERE MADE TO IMPROVE
FUNCTIONALITY A. E. FISHING SEE
OF THE WATER DISH.
UNFORTUNATELY A SOLUTION IS
STILL DESPERATELY NEEDED. THIS
YEAR THE CENTRAL BASIN HAS
SEIZED OPERATING ON THE BASIS
CONSISTENT WITH THE LAW.
IGNORING ADVICE FROM THEIR DâN
LEGAL COUNSEL AND DISOBEYING
THE LOS ANGELES DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S INSTRUCTIONS TO
RESOLVE THOSE NON COMPLIANCE
WITH THE BROWN ACT. THE BOARD
HAS FAILED TO FILL A VACANCY
AND TAKING MAJOR ACTIONS
WITHOUT A QUORUM. OR MAJORITY.
THE LOS ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT
DENIED TO DIRECTORS EMERGENCY
APPLICATION FOR ORDERED THAT
FOR MEMBERS OF THEIR EIGHT
MEMBER BOARD. CONSTITUENTS
CONSTITUTE A MAJORITY DIPPED
ABORT THE COURT WILL NOT BE
CONSIDERING THIS ISSUE UNTIL
JULY TWENTY THIRD. AFTER THE
NEW FISCAL YEAR STARTS AND TOO
LATE FOR THE BOARD TO PUT A
BUDGET IN PLACE. A CONSISTENT
WATER SUPPLY IS ALWAYS JUST BE
CENTRO. IN A WORLD OF COVERT
NINETEEN IT IS EVEN MORE
ESSENTIAL THAT THE SUPPLY
CONTINUES ON INTERRUPTED. TO
JUST REACHED. OF THE BORDER
DIRECT LAST YEAR ROUGH NINE
SECONDS CONCLUDING WITH A
QUESTION OVER WHO WAS CHAIRING
THE COMMITTEE. WHO SHARING THE
MEETING COULD ANSWER THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THE DISTRICT
HAD NOT AND CANNOT BE READ. BY
THE DISTRICT BOARD IS CURRENTLY
ORGANIZED SB SIX TWO FIVE STOPS
THE BLEEDING STABILIZE DISTRICT
BY PLACING IT IN TO
RECEIVERSHIP. ALSO TEN LEE
STITCHING ON TERM OF
CORRECTIONS. ME TO TESTIFY VIA
PHONE. ARE BUILT GROUP KRAUS
FROM THE SAN BASE WATER SO. AND
THAT IS A- CITY MANAGER THE
CITY OF WOULD. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR THOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
JIM SAWYER I PLEASE OPEN LINE.
EITHER BILL CREWS FROM
MCCORMICK PLEASE. AND THE URBAN.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE ON
BILL COULD. THANK FOR THE ARE
TO SPEAK FAVOR THIS WEEK'S
TWENTY A BILL BY BRADFORD TO
FICTION OR ISSUE IN LAW ANGELES
COUNTY. WE ARE. THAT THE WORD.
INTERVENES TO BRING. TO A MAY
FOR DISTRICT THERE'S STILL
FUNCTION NOW CONTROL. I BEEN
ASKED TO SPEAK BEHALF THE
SYNDROME WHAT SERVICE. ABOUT A
GA A THE SEVEN WATER VINCE
VALLEY. THERE THESE ENTITIES
COMPRISE VIRTUALLY EVERY ENTITY
THAT PROVIDES WATER TO
HOUSEHOLDS AND BUSINESSES IN
THE CENTRAL BASIN. THERE IS
OVERWHELMING LOCAL SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. TRANSFORMATION IS IN
CHAOS AND IT HAS BEEN IN CHAOS
FOR YEARS THE BOARD THERE HAS
BEEN UNABLE TO ADDRESS A
COMPLETE AGENDA FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS. I ATTENDED THE LAST
JUNE TELEPHONIC BOARD MEETINGS
MUNSELL ON THOSE TWO MEETINGS
LASTED CUMULATIVELY ABOUT TEN
MINUTES. THE BOARD COULD NOT
COULD COMPLETE A ROLL CALL IN
EACH CASE BUT THEN COULD NOT
ADDRESS A SINGLE ITEM OF
IMPORTANT BUSINESS. MEMBERS
CLASHED OVER WHO WAS PRESIDENT
WHETHER THE ATTORNEY WAS SHALL
BE HIRED HOW MANY NUMBERS
CONSTITUTED A QUORUM. COULD
DIRECTION UP AND WHETHER OR NOT
A MEETING COULD BE SUMMARILY A
JOHN. THE DESTRUCTION THERE IS
SHOCKING AND PULL AND IT
THREATENS THE SUPPLY OF
IMPORTED WATER INTO THE REGION
pHEALTH CRISIS. SEVERAL BASS.
MEMBER AGENCY FOR THE REGION
AND ITS JOB IS TO SECURE
IMPORTANT SUPPLIES OF WATER. IT
DELIVERS REPORTED WATER TO
SPREAD IT COUNTY FACILITIES TO
REPLENISH GROUNDWATER SUPPLIES
IN A PROCESS OVERSEEN BY THE
PROPOSED RECEIVER. PUNISHMENT
CALIFORNIA RED DO NOT PER WATER
FROM JOHN MENTION THEY
PURCHASED WATER FROM CITY ON
OTHER PREPARE SOME OF PORTIONS
FROM AND THEN THEY SERVE THAT
WATER TO NEARLY TWO MILLION
PEOPLE THOSE ARE THE ENTITIES
THAT SUPPORT THIS BILL. PROBLEM
AT CENTRAL BASIN COMMITTEE
CERTAINLY KNOWS ARE NOT. THE
LEGISLATURE TRIED TO FIX THIS
PROBLEM IN TWENTY SIXTEEN BY
ADDING APPOINTED MEMBERS TO THE
BOARD THAT LEGISLATION HAS BEEN
CIRCUMVENTED BY THE SAME GROUP
IMPORTANT CREATED AND NOW
SUSTAIN THE CURRENT CRISIS. THE
PERSON'S ABILITY TO GOVERN
CRIES OUT FOR SB SIX ONE FIVE.
THE BILL WOULD PUT A QUICK STOP
TO THE DYSFUNCTION THROUGH THE
IMMEDIATE ALTHOUGH TEMPORARY
RAM THIRTY IS ACTUALLY LEASE.
IT WAS RELEASED THE WATER
PUNISHMENT DISTRICT A PUBLIC
DISTRICT IS MORE THAN A HALF
CENTURY OF EXPERIENCE MANAGING
AREAS WATER RESOURCES. THE BILL
THEN PROVIDE FOR THE ORDERLY
PUBLIC PROCESS TO GO ASKING
RETURNS WITH THE LEGISLATURE'S
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR A MORE
PERMANENT FIX NEXT YEAR. THAT
IS A PRUDENT RESPONSE TO THIS
SITUATION. EVERY WATER FOR.
SERVICES WE SUPPORTS BILL AND I
JUST REASON FOR THAT IT'S
VITALLY IMPORTANT THAT THIS
ISSUE BE ADDRESSED ESPECIALLY
IN A TIME OF ECONOMIC TURMOIL-
WE RISK EVENTUALLY DEALING WITH
A FAILED BANKRUPT AND NON
FUNCTIONING ENTITY. UNABLE TO
PERFORM ITS CORE FUNCTION OF
SECURING IMPORTANCE OF FIVE
THANK YOU MISTER. SIMMONS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
CREWS- NEXT WILL HAVE THADDEUS
MCCORMICK OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE. AND THE LINE IS OPEN.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
DADDY'S MCCORMICK CITY MAD YOUR
FROM THE CITY OF LAKE WOULD THE
PROBLEMS WITH THE BASE AND-
CENTER BASED IN THEIR SECOND TO
GO BACK A FEW YEARS AND I THINK
ARE WELL DOCUMENTED. I'M NOT
HERE TODAY TO PILE ON OR TO
PLACE BLAME I AM HERE TO TELL
YOU AS A MUNICIPAL PREPARE-
THAT WE HAVE TRIED IN EARNEST
TO WORK WITH THE DISTRICT IN
PARTICULAR OVER THE PAST YEAR-
BUT TO NO AVAIL INTO
CONSIDERABLE FRUSTRATION AND
AGAIN NOT PLACING BLAME CERTAIN
IN MANY ARE PLENTY OF BLAME TO
GO AROUND BUT ONE THING IS
CLEAR. THE DISTRICT HAS
CURRENTLY CONSTITUTED CANNOT
FUNCTION IN FACT IT EXIST IN A
STATE OF DYSFUNCTION SB SIXTY
FIVE BIG WILL STORE WORKING
ORDER ALLOW THE CORE FUNCTIONS
OF THE DISTRICT ARE CUR WHILE
THE FUTURE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
CAN BE A STASHED IN AN
OBJECTIVE. AND UNBIASED MANNER.
YOUR YOUR- LAWN BATTERY AND I
WOULD HAPPY TO QUESTION HOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS MCCALL
WE WILL BE ON TO OTHER IN SO I
SOME ASK YOU FOR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY THANK YOU.
OPERATOR OVER THE LINE PLEASE.
THANK YOU IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT IT WILL BE
A MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER EARLY
WHILE WE PROVIDE LINE NUMBER.
THANK YOU.
AND WE WILL GO TO A
LINE OF THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IN THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE CHECK THE
MUTE BUTTON. HELLO MY OPEN YES
YES YOU ARE I HAD THANK YOU
THANK YOU THIS ROBERT CULP ONE
MAYOR THE CITY SIGNAL HILL AND
THE CITY STRONGLY SUPPORTS SB
SIX TWENTY FIVE AND WOULD LIKE
TO ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS
WELL. THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR. IN MY
OPEN YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JACOB INVOLVED WITH
REPRESENTED THE CITY THE WAKE
WITH IN SIGNAL HILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
PINE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU FOR STATE CALMLY WITH
THE LA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE CHECK YOUR
MUTE BUTTON. LEON TO LINE ONE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING YOUR WOMAN MEMBERS
OFFERED A MEDINA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE GOLDEN STATE
WATER COMPANY IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND LINE FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AGAIN NINE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE CHECK THE MUTE BUTTON.
BRING ON THE LINE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU FOR A LITTLE BIT
BEFORE THE OTHER GROUP THAT.
THE PONDERED WHAT MODIFICATION
I AM THE CHAIR OF THE FOUNTAIN
WATER COALITION BOARD WITH THE
DRUG POLICY FORTY. FIVE THE
ELECTED OFFICIAL FROM THE
THIRTY FATHERS DON'T VALUE
ADDED NOT WALK HIM OUT OF THERE
ARE BENEFITS POINTS THAT. TOPIC
BERMAN AND FINALLY LYDIA OUT
WHILE ALL ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
THE TOPIC WATER POLO BOARD IS
IN FULL SUPPORT OF. THE. TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY THANK YOU. AND MY
FORTY YEAR LAW IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS THE WINTER OF
GENERAL MANAGER BILL MAHER
SOMERSET MUTUAL WATER COMPANY
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. AND NINE ONE ZERO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THE CONSTRUCTING MORE
WHILE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
EXPEDITION OF MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I CAN MAP LINE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
MOVING ON TO LINE ONE ZERO ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE A ONE. IN
MINE ONE HUNDRED AND ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON TO LINE
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE BUTTON.
BRING ON THE LINE FORTY SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE CHECK
YOUR MUTE BUTTON. BRING ON THE
LINE FORTY THREE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT
DIRECTORS ARMY FULL SUPPORT OF
SB SIX HUNDRED FIVE ON OUR
THIRD YOU PLEASE FOR YES VOTE
THANK YOU. COULD THEY PLEASE
REPORTER WHO THAT WAS ON THE
LAST CALL PLEASE. JUST FOR THE
RECORD NINE FORTY THREE NEEDS
REPEAT YOUR NAME. MY NAME IS
JOHN POSSIBLY I'M A BOARD
MEMBER FOR CENTRAL BASIN.
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IN LINE FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JENNIFER
COULD KEEP A LOW WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA WATER AND FIFTY
ASIAN AND APART. LINE AT NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH MY
NAME ARE BURKE LOOK AROUND IS
THAT REPRESENTS SOUTH
MONTEBELLO RECREATION DISTRICT
AND I AM SUPPORT OF- SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU. AND
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS SEEN ON
OUR CONTENT I AM A CURRENT
EMPLOYEE OF CENTRAL BE SENT
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT OF
TWENTY ONE YEARS AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU. AND TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS BILL
ROUNDS MARRIAGE THAT IS SANTA
SANTA FE SPRINGS AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO VOTE YEAH. THANK
YOU. LINE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JOHN SHANAHAN ELSE
NEED LOOK LIKE YOU KNOW TO
PRESIDENT STRONGLY REQUEST THEY
SUPPORT IF AMENDED. WE ASK YOU
TO LOOK AT OUR LETTER WHICH AS
PROTECTION FOR EMPLOYEES WHICH
IS. GOOD DURING THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IT UP
AT. THANK YOU MY NAME XANDER
HELTON I'M ALSO AN EMPLOYEE OF
THE TREASURER AND FINANCE
DIRECTOR AT THE CENTRAL BASIN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. AND ONE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU- NAME MY NAME IS MICHAEL
TERRY GENERAL MANAGER OF THE
HARD RIGHT COUNTY WATER
DISTRICT AND WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT SB SIX TWENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
AT. CONTINUE. HI MY NAME IS
MARGARET TACKLE MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF THE COUNTY AND WE FULLY
SUPPORT SB SIX TWENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE AT THE TIME WE
ARE PROVIDING MY NUMBERS. NINE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YEAH KIM BRIBERY WITH THE
MOBILE IN THE WATER COMPANY
SUPPORTS. THANK YOU. IN MY
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IN MY TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BRING ON TO LINE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR
MIND TWENTY FOUR PLEASE CHECK
YOUR MUTE BUTTON YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NOT TO LINE FORTY ONE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS A MARKER HAD A
PRESIDENT OF THE CENTRAL BASE
AND WATER ASSOCIATION WE FULLY
SUPPORT SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY
FIVE. IN MY NUMBER FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS A LONG BUT I FIGURED I
LIVE N HUNTINGTON PARK WHICH
IS IN THE CENTRAL BASIN WATER
DISTRICT AND AYE OPPOSED SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE BECAUSE THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WERE NOT INFORMED
OF THIS BILL. CURRENTLY WE'RE
JUST TAKING SIGNED AN ORDER
PLEASE. MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS GILBERT LEYVA STADIUM
DOWNEY WE STRONGLY URGE A
AFFIRMATIVE VOE ON THIS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING GETTING
THIS- PARTICULAR IF YOU MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE NOW YES
YES IT IDENTIFIED. SO IS THIS
FOR THE POSTING OR OR OR
RETRIEVER RIGHT NOW I'M JUST
LOOKING THIS IS SUPPORT PLEASE.
ARE NOT COMMON FOR THE OPPOSED.
STAY ON HOLD THEN THANK YOU MAY
NOT. MOVING ON THE LINE ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES HELLO ONE POINT TO
OPPOSE JERRY WAIT YES PLEASE
WAIT THESE ARE WE ARE NOT
TAKING CALLS FOR SUPPORT
MODERATOR CAN WE MAKE SURE WE
CAN FILTER THOSE THROUGH PLEASE.
IT ISN'T A MAN IF YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU ARE
ALREADY CUED UP AND YOU DO NOT
WISH TO SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO TO TAKE YOURSELF.
OUT OF Q. GOING TO LIE NUMBER
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DEMAND A REPEAT CURRENT
APPOINTED DIRECOR CENTRAL
BASIN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
IN FOR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I AM TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MOVING ON
TO LINE AT ONE TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE TWENTY
EIGHT BUT I'M OPPOSED. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE DO NOT
QUEUE UP AT THIS TIME IF YOU
ARE OPPOSED. I THINK IF YOU
HAVE ALREADY CUED UP. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO TAKE
YOURSELF OUT OF Q. AT THE TIME
WE ARE GOING TO LINE NINETEEN.
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MOVING ON TO LINE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON TO
LINE NINETY THREE NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LIVING ON
THE LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M ONE THIRTY
EIGHT BUT I'D ALREADY CLICKED
OF ONE ZERO SHOULD BE ON THE
OPPOSING Q. ALRIGHT. MOVING ON
TO LINE OF ONE TWENTY EIGHT.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON TO
LINE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AT
THIS TIME IF YOU SUPPORT THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAINTHAT IS THE ONE IN
ZERO IF YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DURING THE REGULAR
EMPLOYEE ESSENTIAL BASEMENT I
REPORT SUPPORTERS SB SIX TWENTY
FIVE THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I GET
MY TWENTY MILLION ITEMS OPEN.
LINE AT ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M READY TO BE
ON THE OPPOSING. IS DO NOT
PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE UNTIL
WE AFTER A BOTH THE- ONCE AGAIN
WE'RE TAKING COLORS IN SUPPORT
COLORS IN OPPOSITION WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
MOMENTARILY. BUT AGAIN LATER IN
THE MEN IF YOU WISH TO SUPPORT
LEAVE AT ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
NIGHT. WE DO HAVE ONE QUEUING
UP IT JUST BE A MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THE LIGHT. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE FORTY FIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M A NUMBER OF MENTALLY
DISORDERED AND REPRESENT THE
LAST TWO THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
BETTER CALIFORNIA THE YOUR MAIL
BANGALORE- DAYS COULD BE SEEN
AS A C. R. YOUNG FROM THE RIVER
AND LONG LASTING LARA IT'S SAID
THAT THEY THINK THE SINGLE
BLOCK IN THE VAN UP PRETTY WHAT
THE SABBATH DAY LIVE ONE. EAT A
YOU'LL BAGELS ALMOST ON
VEHICLES WILL THINK THAT IS
SUCCESSFUL MANDATE NINE STRONG
BEYOND ALL LOOKING DIRECTOR OF
THE LOCAL MORE NEED THAT ALVIN
THEN A USER LOVELOCK WALKED
INTO COMPENDIA A YOUR BONUS I
LEAVE ME YOUR NOW DEALS YOU
KNOW YOUR OWN. MAN THE MAIL FOR
YOU KNOW. HOLD THIS CALL CAN
GIVE A CALL IN FOR THE
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HER VOICE WILL BE HEARD MY- BY
NOW THIRTY THREE LIGHT AT THE-
AGAIN LINE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS A. LIVING ON THE LINE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY
NAME IS FIVE APODACA PRESIDENT
OF CENTRAL BASE WATER DISTRICT
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THE LINE NUMBER ONE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DIRECTOR AND BE I AM THE
ACCOUNTING MANAGER ADVENTURE
BASED IN AND I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT DOCTOR SB SIX TWO FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND THERE
ARE NO OTHER. CALLERS LINED UP
AT THE PARK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR. LIST MODERATOR
LIST YOU ONE LAST CALL FOR
SUPPORT WE WILL DO THE SAME
THING PROPOSITION BUT IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE FOR SUPPORT.
DELAYED AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ACTIVE PINE. WE
WILL GO TO THE LINE OF TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
TWENTY FOUR HAD DROPPED OUT OF
YOU. IT JUST BE A MOMENT. AND
THEY'RE BACK IN QUEUE. LINE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN BE
VERY HIGH. WITH WATER RESOURCES
MANAGER CENTER BASED MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT AND ONE OF THE
SIXTEEN YOUR DEPARTMENT MANAGER
THAT I FULLY SUPPORT SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY I KNOW THAT. HELLO HELLO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN YES WE. HI THIS
IS SHERIN KUMAR AND I'M THE
EMPLOYEE OF CENTRAL BASE
ADMISSIBLE POTTER DISTRICT FOR
THE PAST THIRTEEN YEARS AND I
SUPPORT IS SB SIX TWENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HELLO MY NAME THE
LEARNING I AM A REPAIR AND I DO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT
WILL MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION OUR
FIRST PRESENT PRESENTER IS THE
TV SHOW OF ALL SCORES WILSON
FROM THE CENTRAL BASIN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT. IF
YOU. WOULD LIKE TO COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE. WELCOME THANK
YOU ARE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE-
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LET THE
SERVE OSCARS WILSON I CURRENTLY
SERVE AS THE BOARD PRESIDENT OF
THE CENTRAL BASIN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT. I'M A FORMER
MAYOR AS CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
AND FORMER LEGISLATIVE STAFFER
TO THE LATE HONORABLE MARVIN
TIMELY AND AN EDUCATOR IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. ARE WE ARE NOT HERE
TODAY BECAUSE CENTRAL BASIN IS
DELIVERING DIRTY WATER WE'RE
NOT HERE TO DAY BECAUSE CENTRAL
BASIN HAS STOPPED DELIVERING. A
WATER TO OVER TWO MILLION
PEOPLE IT SERVES AND WE'RE ALSO
NOT HERE TO DATE BECAUSE THERE
IS ANY MISSING OR STOWING MONEY
AT CENTRAL BASIN. WERE HERE
TODAY BECAUSE A SMALL GROUP OF
PRIVATE INTERESTS WANT TO TAKE
OVER OUR COMMUNITIES WATER
SYSTEM IT'S ALMOST. ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF ASSETS. THIS
WELL ACTED IN OUR THIS IS ON MY
REPRESENTATION AND I URGE YOU
TO SAY NO TO SB SIX TWENTY
FIVE. THE FACTS ARE CENTRAL
BASIN IS SOLVENT. CENTRAL
BASINS BONDS ARE IN GOOD
STANDING. CENTRAL BASINS BILLS
ALL PAID. THIS BILL IS FILLED
WITH SO MANY MISREPRESENTATIONS
ABOUT THE STATUS OF THE CENTRAL
BASIN THAT I'VE SUBMITTED FOR
THE RECORD AND I BELIEVE EACH
OF YOU HAVE A PACKET. OUR LET
ME GO THROUGH SOME OF THOSE
MISREPRESENTATIONS FIRST THE
BILL ANALYSIS SITES THAT THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AS
THE GROUP HAS- ENDORSED THIS
MEASURE IT HASN'T THE BOARD HAS
NEVER PASSED A RESOLUTION TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THE SOUTHEAST
WATER COALITION ALSO HAS NEVER
VOTED TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
THIS CITIES OF DOWNEY AND LAKE
WOULD HAVE NOT. VOTED ARE TO
PASS A RESOLUTION TO SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE THE CENTRAL BASIN
WATER ASSOCIATION ALSO HAS NOT
VOTED AS A GROUP TO HAVE A
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION AND
NEITHER HAS THE CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION. THIS BILL
AND ITS ANALYSIS MAKES NUMEROUS
REFERENCES TO A TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN STATE AUDIT BUT IT ALSO
FAILS TO MENTION THAT ALL OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THAT
ARE THAT HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
INSTITUTED. IT ALSO FAILED TO
TELL YOU THAT THE BOARD MEMBERS
THAT WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE
AUDIT FINDINGS ARE NO LONGER ON
THE BOARD WE'VE HAD FIVE
ELECTIONS AFTER THAT AUDIT AND
WE HAVE A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
BOARD THIRTY SECONDS PLEASE THE
PLAIN AND SIMPLE TRUTH HERE IS
THAT THIS BILL IS AN EFFORT TO
DISENFRANCHISE OUR COMMUNITIES
OF COPPER. BY ELIMINATING ITS
ELECTED BY LEE BODY SITE SEEING
OVER TWENTY TWO MILLION
CITIZENS TO REPRESENT OUR WHO
REPRESENT THE COMMUNITY AND IS
AN EFFORT BY A SMALL PRIVATE
GROUP. OF INTERESTED WHOSE SOLE
PURPOSE TEN IS TO TAKE. AND
PRIVATIZE OUR PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEM IT WAS DONE AT CITY THE
WATER DISTRICT UNFORTUNATELY.
WHAT'S BEING DONE AT CENTRAL
BASIN AND I URGE YOUR NO
SUPPORT ON SB SIX TWENTY FIVE
THANK YOU I'M HERE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
ABOUT THIS GREAT THANK YOU
MUCH. I WILL NOT HAVE IT THEY
WILL PAVE PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON DOUG GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AT THE NEW WILL BE
ON BEHALF OF THE DIRECTORS OF
CENTRAL BASIN. I JUST WANNA
DRESSED THE THINGS THAT ARE
RAISED IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THE FIRST THING IS THAT CENTRAL
BASES IN DISARRAY. HOWEVER
THERE ARE NO FAXES SUPPORTED
DISARRAY. ARE THEIR
DISAGREEMENTS THERE ARE
DISAGREEMENTS AND ONE OF THEM
IS TO BE HEARD JULY TWENTY
THIRD BY THE COURT AND THIS IS
AN ATTEMPT TO MAKE AN END RUN
AROUND THE COURT'S DECISION ON
A CRITICAL ISSUE. THE SECOND
POINT REYES OF IN SUPPORT OF
THE ANALYSIS IS THAT FOR
MEMBERS TOOK OVER THE DISTRICT.
THE FOUR MEMBERS OF NEVER TOOK
OVER THE DISTRICT ON JANUARY
THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR THERE
WAS A REORGANIZATION. AND THE
VOTE WAS FOR THREE TO ELECT A
NEW PRESIDENT THOUGH FIRST
FEMALE PRESIDENT OF CENTRAL
BASIN. THE OLD JUN. PARTIES TO
THIS MATTER DISAGREED WITH THAT
AND REFUSE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
REORGANIZATION. THERE'S NO
THREAT TO THE WATER SUPPLY.
THERE'S A ISSUE IN HERE THAT IS
A THREAT TO WATER SUPPLY IS
ABSOLUTELY NO THREAT TO WATER
SUPPLY THERE HAS BEEN A MISSED
DELIVERY WATER IS BEEN PROVIDED
TO EACH AND EVERY CONSTITUENTS.
THE FOUR THING. THE IN THEIR
ANALYSIS THEY SHOULD THE SITE
HUNTINGTON PARK VERSES THE
SCHOOL E. WHO JUST CALLED IN
PREVIOUSLY AND IS THAT
APPOINTED MEMBER. HE CREATED A
SITUATION THAT CALLS LITIGATION
BE FILED BY LAUNCHING PARK
NAMING HIM. THE REASON WHY THEY
NAMED HIM IS THE PROBLEM WITH
WHAT HAPPENED WITH MISS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA'S
PREVIOUS BILL WITH THESE
APPOINTED MEMBERS THE GENERAL
MANAGER WAS DESIGNATED WOULD
OPENING BALLOTS WHEN YOU OPEN
HUNTINGTON PARKS BALLOT HE
DECIDED HE DIDN'T LIKE CLINTON
PARKS APPOINTEE AND DISMISSED
TOM AND THEREFORE HUNTINGTON
PARK FILED A LAWSUIT IT WASN'T
GOOD CENTRAL BASIN. WAS AGAINST
DIRECTED WAS COOLEY WHO IS AN
APPOINTEE AND THAT CASES CITED
IN YOUR ANALYSIS. AS TO THE
ISSUES YES THERE IS A- THE
ISSUE FOR JANUARY- JULY TWENTY
THIRD ISSUES WHETHER NOT THE
REORGANIZATION ON JANUARY
THIRTIETH WAS PROPER. AND
THAT'S A LEGAL ISSUE BUT IN
ORDER TO SKATE. OR SKIRT TO
LEGAL ISSUE THE PARTIES ARE
ATTEMPTED TO MAKE A AND RUN
WITH THISCOMMITTEE. AND TO
HAVE YOU DRAFT AN EMERGENCY
BILL FOR WHICH THERE IS NO
EMERGENCY. THERE IS NOTHING-
PREVENT IN THE PARTY FROM
WAITING A TO JOT JULY TWENTY
THIRD TO HEAR THE COURT'S
DECISION. THIRTY SECONDS PLACE.
I SUBMIT TO THIS BILL- AUGUST
BODY THAT. WHAT YOU'RE CHARGED
WITH IS MAKING SURE THAT THE
VARIOUS AGENCIES WITHIN THE
STATE FUNCTION APPROPRIATELY
SENT TO. THE BODY WANTS TO GO
BACK AND RE LIVED ISSUES THAT
HAPPENED LONG BEFORE THIS BOARD
WAS PRESENT PRESENTLY THE FOUR
MEMBERS OF THE FOR ELECTED
OFFICIALS IT IS THE APPOINTED
MEMBERS OF BECAUSE THE DISARRAY
AND REFUSED TO ACKNOWLEDGE A
FEMALE PRESIDENT THANK YOU
MISTER WILLOUGHBY. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR WE PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINE FOR THOSE. THAT OPPOSE THE
BILL PLEASE. THANK YOU IF YOU
OPPOSE THE BILL PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THE TIME.
ALRIGHT WE'LL GO TO NINE
NINETEEN LINE NINETEEN YEAR YOU
ARE OPEN. NOPE. MY NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. BOB EIGHT
FIVE FIVE GABLE IMMEDIATE-
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT UP FORTY NINE
ELECTED CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY DELEGATES. I AM A STRONG
WE OPPOSE BOTH NO THE SB FIVE
X. SB AT SIX FIVE OUR WATER IS
LIFE IN IT SHOULD NOT BE
PRIVATIZED THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS TRAILER BOSCO I
LIVING CUTTING A AYE OPPOSED
THE BILL SB SIX TWENTY FIVE
BECAUSE I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
IT'S BENEFICIAL FOR RESIDENT AT
THE END OF THE DAY I BELIEVE
THAT THAT DID THE ONLY THING
THIS IS GOING TO DO IS
PRIVATIZE OUR WATER. AND TAKE
OVER MORE OF OUR RIGHT IF YOU
SEE THE PEOPLE THAT THE
MODERATOR- NET OR SOME PLEASE
LET ME JUST REMIND EVERYONE ALL
WITNESSES JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND IF YOU OPPOSE
THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
EARNERS VOTER IN THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES AND THE NUMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS IN ON HE
HEAD AT A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
JOHN FOR YOUR FOR KILLING. ALL
O. MONTEREY NEXT PERSON PLAYS
LET ME JUST REMIND EVERYONE. WE
WANT TO HEAR YOU BUT WE ALSO
I'M ASKING FOR IS YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION CAN IMPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOUR LINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
MICHAEL RINCON WITH PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LOS
ANGELES- WE STRONGLY- OPPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
THAT. OUR NEXT PERSON PLEASE.
PINE I NEED TO OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS MARIA. AND I AM THE DIRECTOR.
I AM ALSO AN ELECTED- CENTER
COUNTY COMMITTEE- DELEGATE AND
I'M HERE. ALL RIGHT OPPOSE FOR
THE PEOPLE OF SOUTHEAST LA NOT
BEEN INFORMED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT MODERATOR NEXT PERSON
PLEASE. PINE EIGHTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH CONOR EVER
THE CALIFORNIA WATERSHED
ALLIANCE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT
NINE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IN THAT LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BEING ON THE LINE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
FORTY NINE PLEASE CHECK YOUR
MUTE BUTTON. MOVING ON TO LINE
NINETY THREE NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M HI MY NAME IS
NOT A GOOD TIME QUE I AM A
CONSTITUENT OF SOUTHEAST GO
THANK YOU LET ME AND MY
CHILDREN'S GLADLY URGE YOU TO
VOTE AGAINST SB SIX TWENTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BY NOT GETTING UP THERE WOULD A
MEMBER OF THE PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRATS OF LOS ANGELES FROM
WE BOTH THE BILL IF IT
DEMOCRATIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE
SIXTY THREE OR LINE OF THE.
HELLO HELLO WE CANNOT HELP ME
YES WE CAN HI MY NAME EL CAMINO.
HI I'M ALLISON MILLER I'M A
LONG BEACH BUT IN CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUENTS AGAIN BUT THAT ALL
THANK YOU VERY. NINE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
GOOD MORNING OUT FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PARTY LAW AND I
CALLING IN AND- WE'LL SEE SOME
IDEAS BE ALL THESE BE UP. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LINE ONE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IN JAMISON DATA REVIEW
HAVE CERTAIN BOARD MEMBERS
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE ROBERT
AFTERSHOCK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LOOKS LIKE HIGH CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES I CAN'T LEAP AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH GUT
FEELING I'M A RESIDENT OF LAKE
WHAT AND AYE OPPOSED TO SELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN
THAT LINE NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD HELLO MY THERAPIST AMY
YES WE CAN. OKAY MY NAME IS
TERRA PATRICIA WENT DON'T I AM
A RESIDENT OF CARMEL CALIFORNIA
I'M ALSO IN WATER ADVOCATE
MEMBER OF SOCIAL EAGLE
EDUCATION AND I UPHOLD MY STOP
AND MY FAMILY STRONGLY OPPOSE-
BILL S. SIX TWENTY FIVE. THANK.
MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES TO MY NAPA
NUMBER CARL FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTY SEVEN NO
PRIVATIZATION OF WATER CENTRAL
WATER BEINGVERY NICE NO AND
WHAT IF. YOU BOUGHT. THANK YOU
MY NUMBER EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IN THAT LINE
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MIND YOU GET. YES I CAN YES AT
SO. HELLO MY NAME DROP WHEN
OTHER GROWN VIDEO SUCKING IN
CENTRAL BASIN I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB SIXTY FIVE BECAUSE- MUCH. WE
WILL GO TO THE LINE OF THE
FIFTY FOUR FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AGAIN THAT'S LINE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT MOVING ON TO LINE FIFTY
FIVE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I AM FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO TO HIM YES THE CAT
HELLO MY NAME IS A MAN WALKS
AND PANORAMA CONCERNED CITIZEN
AND THE FUTURE OF PER-
PARTICIPANT THAT WILL BE
GREATLY AFFECTED IN THIS IN
THIS BILL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SB SIX TO FIND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MY NUMBER
ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IT UP BUT-
HI MY NAME IS JR HE HE BORROWER
I'M A RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF
SULKY AND MY FAMILY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER ONE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE GET A LOOK AT. OKAY
PERFECT MY NAME IS LORRAINE
MORE AND I AM ACTUALLY A
COMMISSIONER FOR THE CITY OF
LYNNWOOD. AND I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT THE WAY THIS BILL ¢H US
WRITTEN. AND IS STILL I. ONLY
THANK YOU VERY. BLOOD RAIDER
NEXT FITNESS. MY NUMBER ONE
FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME'S JEFFREY MORE
OUTLETS I'M A RESIDENT OF BELL
AND I AM AGAINST SB SIX TWENTY
FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WHEN
I NUMBER ONE HUNDRED FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
DANIEL SHOWN I'M A RESIDENT OF
LA COUNTY AND I BOTH THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ROCHELLE
SHAW I AM A RESIDENT OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AGAIN THAT MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN. MOVING ON
TO MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED FORTY
FIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE OF
THE MAIN NUMBER THIS MAN LEE
AND WE SOLD IT FOR THE RIGHT
PERSON TO LEAD TO THAT AND
THEN. HE YOUR MAIL COMMINGLED
OCCUPIES A LOT OF PROPOSES HE
OWNED A SERVICE A LINK IS
SINGLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HE
HAD. ACT THE LAST LINE. OKAY MY
NUMBERS IN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO HELLO. YES SALLY HANDLES
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RETIRED AND I AM
CALLING TO STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BILL I FEEL IT'S UNNECESSARY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE
NUMBER ONE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IN THAT ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BRING ON THE LINE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN THAT BY
NUMBER SIXTY SIX. HELLO HELLO
HELLO HELLO HELLO YES MY NAME
IS COMING GONZALEZ I LIVE IN
THE CITY OF CAR HEY I'M AGAIN
SB. SIX TWO FIVE. THANK YOU MY
NUMBER NINE SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AGAIN I'D LIE NUMBER
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MEET A FAN ON IT RIGHT NOW BELL
AND I OUT A GAME IF IT BE OLD
SB. SIX SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER NINETY BILLION
NINE ADULT. AGAIN AT MY NUMBER
NINETY TWO YEAR OLD. OKAY WE'RE
GETTING FEEDBACK ON THAT LINE
MOVING ON TO LINE NUMBER ONE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO VERY GOOD LIVES YES WE
CAN. HI MY NAME IS I'M FROM THE
WATER DO YOU TAKE PART IN. AND
I WILL HOLD SB SIX FIVE THANK
YOU COMPARE. LINE NUMBER SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME IS
DAVE SIMON IT IS AN OF. THE
CITY OF DELEGATE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB SIX BUT- THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED THANK YOU
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. OKAY MY NAME IS
MAURICE. I'M ATTORNEY IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB SIX TWO BY. RIGHT MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO HELLO HELLO
WE CAN HEAR IT. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN YES AT ALL OKAY
SORRY THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
I'VE EVER HI MY NAME IS MELANIE
CULLEN I AM- MEMBER UP FOOD AND
WATER ACTION ALSO AN EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE MEMBER OF THE SIERRA
CLUB BUT ALEX BERTIE SOUTH BAY
AND WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
SB SIX TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
NUMBER SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS ON THE COME
OUT FROM A RESIDENT ON FRIDAY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE TO FUND I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR. I NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES GOOD MORNING
TO HEAR ME YES WE CAN WE CAN.
OKAY I AM A CONCERN THAT IF
NONE OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
I FIRMLY OPPOSE SB SIX TWO FIVE
AND YOUR NAME PLEASE AND YOUR
NAME PLEASE. MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. OKAY MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I'M AN INSURANCE JONES
ROBERT APODACA CONFIDENTIAL
BASIS SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN A SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIM OPPOSED AT THE
FIVE. X. CALLER. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MIKE YEAH NINE. AT MY NUMBER
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS CRISTINA GARCIA KNOWS MY
NAME I'M FROM THE ORGANIZATION
THAT PROTEST FOR HOUSE IN BELL
GARDENS THROUGH THE VULTURE
LAND LAURIE AND I. PLEASE. THE
END OF MY NUMBER TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES CAN OKAY.
YES MY NAME IS MARY LOU MADA
I'M A RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
AND AN ADVOCATE FOR WATER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SELLING MONEY
FOR SHORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR NEXT LINE IS FIFTY FOUR
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GET
MINE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LIVING ON TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FOR HOW LONG HELLO
YEAH YEAH. YET THIS IS NOT YOUR
FROM THE DOCKING. AND I'M
CALLING TO- CLOSE- GOOD IN
AMEND BILL I ALSO WANT TO
RETRACT THE CITY OF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT NEXT CALLER
PLEASE MODERATOR. MY NUMBER
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS A LONG ENOUGH
TO GET OUR ELEVEN HUNTINGTON
PARK IN THE FEDERAL CASE THE
WATER DISTRICT THAT I HOPE WILL
SB SIX TWO BY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LINE NUMBER NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE OF THE- HI. OKAY ME
OUT MY NAME IS GOING TO PASS T
I AM THANKFUL COUNTY COMMITTEE
MEMBER- BUT THE SECOND TIME
AROUND I RECHARGE UCLA HEALTH
REPRESENTED AT THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT SENTIDO DEMOCRATIC
CLUB AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. THE
THAT SIX TWO FIVE AND SHAME ON
THE VERY MUCH FUN NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
THAN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS A
ONE THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. AND
LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN. MY NAME
IS TAMMY CARDONA ZOMBIES THEN
THE LA RESIDENT AND ARE
CONCERNED NUMBER OF THE- LOCAL
AREA I HAVE A BOOK STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB ONE SIX TWENTY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I NUMBER ONE
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AGAIN NINE ONE SIX BEFORE.
HELLO HELLO IF I HAD LOW. HI MY
NAME IS BYRON ERA I LIVE IN THE-
THANK YOUNG PART COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SIX TWENTY
FIVE THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS KERRY SCOVILLE
I'M A RESIDENT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND A CONSTITUENT IN
STEVEN BRADFORD TO DISTRICT A
MEMBER OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IN NINETEEN OPEN.
HELLO YEAH I HAD MY DS THE
AMENDMENT BILL ISSUES I'M JOHN
AND THE PEOPLE THAT CUSHION A
THROUGH HAVE ALL RECEIVED
DONATIONS. WRITER PLEASE NEXT
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY NUMBER
ONE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I AM BILINGUAL INDO
REMEMBER MENTAL JUST COALITION
FOR WATER AND WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. LINE NUMBER FIFTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOR NINE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HELLO IF I HAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ROXANNE
ALL CALM COOL AND COLLECTED
UNITS COMING FROM CLARK AND I
STRONGLY THING NO TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU. I NUMBER ONE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN
HELLO NUMBER ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD WE CAN
HEAR YOU. EXCUSE HELLO HELLO WE
GO AHEAD YOU. YEAH I JUST WANT
TO REMIND PEOPLE OF LAKE
MICHIGAN AND HOW THEY PRIVATIZE.
THE WATER THERE MONTEREY OUR-
ALLY NUMBER ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH SITE I
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP WITH
COMMENTS AND WANT TO KNOW WHEN
THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE. HELLO I
DIDN'T I DIDN'T HEAR YOU I'M
SORRY. WE'RE JUST RIGHT NOW
WE'RE JUST TAKING AIM
ORGANIZATION AND IF YOUR IF YOU
OPPOSE THE BILL. OKAY I'LL JUST
HANG ON THE LINE AND WAIT GIVE
MY COMMENTS. MODERATE MY NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN AGAIN ONE THIRTY. NINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS DAVID BURGER THE
PARK TO DRIVERS ARE THE PUBLIC
WATER VOTE NO ON SB SIX ZERO
FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY THERE
DROPPED MY NUMBER THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN WE CAN. MY
NAME IS RON WILSON I'M A
LICENSED ATTORNEY I PRACTICE IN
LOS ANGELES I OPPOSE SB SIX TWO
BY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OUTSTANDING MAKE. YEAH MY
OPEN. ALRIGHT MOVING ON WE DO
HAVE ANOTHER ONE CUED UP IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IT JUST BE A MOMENT
WHILE WE PROVIDE MY NUMBERS.
OKAY LINE LINE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO HELLO YOU
ARE REMINDED OPEN PEOPLE HAD.
HI. NINE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO LET ME IN HERE
YOU. OKAY MOVING ON THE LINE
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I CAN I CAN LOOK IT UP NO
ONE OF THE SIX TWO FIVE. THANK
YOU MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. MY
NUMBER ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN WE CAN WELL. MY
NAME IS VICTORIA SAID BY IN-
ACOSTA INSTEAD OF TEN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL SB SIX.
MY NUMBER ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
AT BUT ON SOME YEARS NOT I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF EACH
A. B. W. STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. RIGHT NUMBER
ONE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GIVE OUR REASONING I'M WRITING
HERE- CLEARLY YOU JUST IT IS
JUST THE STATE YOUR NAME AND
OPPOSITION. ALL I'M SORRY YEAH
I ALREADY I ALREADY DID SO.
THANK YOU MAY I NUMBER ONE
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AGAIN ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MOVING ON TO LINE
NUMBER ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEP ALTHOUGH NO
ONE SIX TWO FIVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MY NUMBER NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AGAIN NUMBER
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY NO ONE IS
ON THAT LINE WE ARE GATHERING
ONE MORE PERSON WHO IF IT
HAPPENED AT THE MOMENT. THANK
YOU. BY NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI I AM CALLING
IT I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU MAYBE HAVE YOUR
NAME PLEASE. OKAY MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
VOTE FOR THE BILL WERE
PROTESTING OUTSIDE THE HOUSE NO
ONE. OKAY THERE ARE NO OTHERS
TO THE PROPOSITION AT THE TIME.
WE WILL DO A LAST CALL IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE THE BILL
PLEASE CALL IN NOW. THIS IS THE
YEAR YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION.
WE'VE HAD ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL
AT THE HI. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO THE LINE OF ONE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON.
WE THOUGHT HEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON IT'S A. I HAVE A
QUESTION WHAT WILL WE BE ABLE
TO MAKE COMMON. WHY WE ARE GET
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND IF YOU OPPOSE THE BILL.
CAROLINE OF EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON TO
LINE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH GOT THE
ON A MEMBER OF THE CENTRAL
COUNTY A COMMITTEE ALSO READY
FOR STATE SENATOR THIRTY THIRD
DISTRICT AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
SB SIX TWO FIVE. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI YES ON MICHAEL'S
PRETTY GOT HE'S CALLING FROM
SANTA MONICA CALIFORNIA AND AS
A DEMOCRAT I OPPOSE THE- BILL
SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NOT ARE FACTORED PUBLIC
WATERING WATCH A LOTTERY OR
PLEASE TAKE HIM OFF THE PHONE
PLEASE THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS DIANA PART METER AND
OPPOSE SB SIX TWO FIVE THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES ANTHONY
RICARDO ONCE AGAIN NO ONE SIX
TWO FIVE THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OUR WATER. I DO APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT HE KEEPS DIALING INTO
DIFFERENT NUMBERS. MY NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN ACT I DON'T. OKAY
MOVING ON. THIS POINT I BELIEVE
WE HAVE AB REPEAT OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE CALLERS ON BOTH SIDES FIRST
WE NEXT HAVE SOME TIME THE
PEOPLE HERE IN OUR AUDIENCE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO. OPPOSE THE
BILL IN YOUR NAME YOUR-
REALIZATION- I WOULD LIKE TO GO
ON RECORD IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX TWENTY FIVE MY NAME IS
MARTHA COME MUCH RODRIGUEZ I'M
A CONSTITUENT OF THE DISTRICT
AND I AM ALSO DIRECTOR ON THE
WATER BOARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SIR ANYONE ELSE IN THE
AUDIENCE WOULD LIKE TO. JUST
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
IF YOU OPPOSE THE BILL OR
SUPPORTED. MY NAME IS ART
CHACON I'M ALSO DIRECTOR WITH
CENTRAL BASE AND I'M ALSO A NEW
ELECTED- WITH THE SCENT JOBS.
DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL COMMITTEE.
AND I OPPOSE SIX. TWO FIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDRESS.
ALL RIGHT- AND WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE OKAY. CARLOS PINERO
INTERIM GENERAL MANAGER AT
CENTRAL BASIN AND OPPOSE THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE GALLERY. SEEING
NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE HOW DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. YES
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE THANK YOU
SO THIS IS JUST OUR WORK TO MY
AREA QUITE A BIT TO MUNICIPAL
LIES WATER SYSTEMS BUT AS I
READ THROUGH THIS ALL THE
SYSTEMS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT OUR PUBLIC AND WE'RE
GIVING AUTHORITY TO LASKO WHICH
ONLY DEALS WITH PUBLIC PUBLIC
AGENCIES SO IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE
THE PRIVATIZATION ISSUE HERE'S
A BIT OF A RED HERRING. IN
ADDITION IT AND YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT IN ADDITION
UNDER RECEIVERSHIP WOULD BE
UNDER WOULD BE PUBLIC ALSO THE
WATER REPLENISHED REPENTED TO
MAKE DISTRICT. IS ALSO. PUBLIC
AND ELECTED. SO IT STILL
REMAINS IN THE PUBLIC DOMAIN-
ACTED IF I WERE TO ADD. IN FACT
IF THE SENATOR WHO'S THE AUTHOR
IS BILL OR MYSELF BUT THAT.
THIS WOULD BECOME PUBLIC WE
WOULD UP OBVIOUSLY OPPOSE IT BY
ANY MEANS NECESSARY. AND IF
PEOPLE HAVE ANY INFORMATION
HOPEFULLY THIS IS BILL MOVES
FOR- TEST CONTRARY TO THAT.
EITHER LAUGH GO ORDER WATER
REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT WE WOULD
LOVE TO GET EVIDENCE TO THAT
BUT RIGHT NOW IT STAYS. IN THE
PUBLIC IT STAYS IN THE
COMMUNITY THE SPACE IN THE
PEOPLE'S WATER. THANK YOU
BECAUSE IT THIS MOVES TO
PRIVATIZE WATER SYSTEMS AND I
DEFINITELY HAVE A PROBLEMWITH
THAT SO SODA I APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION- MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE WE HAVE A MOTION AND WE
HAVE A SECOND BY MISTER RIVAS.
THOSE ARE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. OKAY SEEING NONE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER BOB
THANK YOU AND I THINK WE AS
HOPEFULLY THIS BILL MOVES FOR
THAT WE DON'T STOP THE
DISCUSSION WE DON'T STOP
HAVING- INFORMATION COME IN TO
MAKE THIS BILL BETTER BECAUSE I
THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY AS
THE MORE INFORMATION WE GET AS
WE HAVE CLARIFIED INFORMATION
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF FACTS
GOING BACK AND FORTH IF WE ONCE
WE GET THE TRUTH I THINK WE'LL
BE ABLE TO MOVE. FORWARD IN A
WAY ULTIMATELY- EVERYBODY WILL
BE SATISFIED. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I'D LIKE TO CORRECT
A COMMENT REGARDING THE
POSITION OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ON
THIS BILL. AS REFLECTED IN THE
ANALYSIS THE BOARD OF BOARD
SUBMITTED A LETTER IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL DATED MAY TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY WHICH WE
HAVE ON FILE SO JUST O. THAT
THIS CLARIFIED I DIDN'T WANT TO
OVERLOOK. OF THE LETTER THAT
COME IN- ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU FOR PRESENTING THE BILL IN
HALF OF A SENATOR BRADFORD. I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
THEN FOR WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE LOCAL LAUGH GO AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. I APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING THE AUTHOR IN THE
CALL OTHERS ARE DOING TO ENSURE
THE SAFE AND COST EFFECTIVE
PROVISION OF DRINKING WATER. IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES. EVEN WITH
PASSED LEGISLATIVE INTERVENTION
THE DISTRICT CONTINUES TO
STRUGGLE WITH GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCIAL ISSUES. IN LIGHT OFTHE CURRENT CODE NINETEEN
CRISIS IT IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER TO ESTABLISH A
GOVERNANCE. THE SAFEGUARDS YOUR
RESIDENTS DRINKING WATER. I
BELIEVE THE AUTHOR HAS CREATED
A REASONABLE SOLUTION TO
DISCOVER THE BEST COURSE. FOR
RELIABLE WATER SERVICE FOR
YEARS TO COME. I ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO EVERYONE'S
CONTINUED WORK ON THIS. ISSUE
JUST TO CLARIFY AMENDMENTS WILL
BE ADOPTED TODAY TO ADD AN
URGENCY CLAWS AND MAKE
ADDITIONAL MINOR CHANGES THIS-
MY RECOMMENDATION IS TO DO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS OF AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
HI AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY LACKEY
AYE BLOOM. BLOOM HI
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
EYES STONE. STONE I THREE OF US
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL. VOEPEL
II. BIG BOB DOLE GETS OUT EIGHT
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE
APPRECIATE THANK YOU ON BEHALF
CENTER BRADFORD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK. OKAY ALRIGHT WE
WILL ADJOURN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE MEETING
THANK YOU ALL